it's called Mario RPG remake and it has
a lot of RPG elements but like this
isn't like Persona 5 this got it I'm
almost at the end of the I'm at I almost
say CU adct it's your first time playing
I'm let's put it this way I'm like if I
really play it right I'm like 30 minutes
away from the last boss wow see put like
and that's and that's not that's because
I'm a a grizzled veteran like I already
know what I'm doing what doing all my
characters all my characters is maxed
out at the max level which I'm not going
to say which I'm not adct cuz I'm not
going to say what the the max level is
but the max level leveling ain't even
high and then like with you you can
equip a certain accessory with the fraud
coins because fra coins I can say
they'll buy you certain items these fra
coins wasn't in the old one they were
okay but they just more easier you had
to you had to grind the okay so that's
what makes it okay I got you yeah so you
had to really grind and get it they
upgraded they up